what's up guys
lunch money time wednesday bang
bang well washington trying to get rich
look at that new music well wall
street's trying to get rich the rest of
us just trying to get our lunch money
right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
plana
evilova marinova pompliano p-i-m-p
maybe that's what we're gonna do we'll
get some intro music p-i-m-p no
don't forget lunch money is now
presented by blockfi
go and get an interest bearing account
you
can use the link in the description it
is blockfy.com
lunch money no-brainer you can earn up
to 8.6
interest it literally keeps your cash
with state street
and then it turns it into a digital
dollar and earns you high rates of
interest
duh go do it i did the whole ads and the
intro
in 50 seconds what's up great
great well are you sleepy right now you
know it's gonna wake you up a little bit
let's go
oh my god yeah by screaming in my ear
and that's really gonna happen
you know what's not great what united
airlines losing 1.6 billion in the
second quarter
but expects to further lower its cash
burn
i don't believe them why not it's not
gonna get better
why does any get better because cases
are rising and things are shutting down
again
no i think it's gonna get better really
yeah well i mean look they lost 1.63
billion dollars in the second quarter
which is driven by a plunge in air
travel demand uh during the same quarter
last year they posted a one billion
dollar profit
so to give you a sense that's a 2.6
billion dollar swing so they made a
billion dollars a quarter last year
now they're losing 1.6 billion there's a
pretty big gap
and so i just don't believe that uh it's
going to get
much much worse like yeah maybe they
lose another billion and a half next
quarter or something like that
but i do believe over um kind of the
medium term
uh you're gonna see people going back we
are gonna fly again
like revenue's gonna get revenue is
going to come back
uh and also they're doing all sorts of
cash cutting measures so you'll see them
kind of eat into those losses
hopefully maybe they can get into uh
some sort of positive cash flow position
the
crazy stat revenue plunged 1.48 billion
dollars
in the three months ending june 30th
which is an 87
drop from 11.4 billion during the same
time last year seven percent is no joke
guys
so to be honest the fact that they only
lost
1.6 billion dollars but revenue went
down 86
87 percent i mean
sounds pretty crazy but like some people
would argue actually doing a pretty good
job
i don't know you don't think are you
yawning are you sleepy right now i was i
was so let me tell the people i had to
wake you up tonight uh
today to get you to come do lunch money
i was sleeping and he woke me up that's
why i'm a little out of it but
like a big big sleep okay what's going
on mortgages don't call me big sleep
um weekly mortgage demand from home
buyers jumps
even higher up 19 annually
well it's up 4.1 the mortgage
applications last week
yes in fact last week not not annually
and it was up 5
last week which is like 120 uh
refinances
are up like 120 year over year and so
again we talked about this a million
times why are so many homes being bought
why are so many mortgage applications
going in
because there's cheap capital flooding
the market right now capital means
what cheap capital just means you can
borrow money and not have to pay a bunch
of interest on it so
historically if you had to borrow money
and you were paying five or six percent
interest on it
over a 30-year mortgage right now you
can go and get a 30-year
fixed-rate mortgage at less than three
percent
wild right so basically why would you
not
either one go borrow money to buy a home
today and lock in the
under three percent fixed rate or
if you're sitting there and you're
paying four and a half five percent of
your mortgage why would you not
refinance it down to a three
percent or less interest rate of course
you're going to do that apparently the
nation's home builders are seeing strong
and serious buyer traffic
as consumers now get used to purchasing
homes they've only seen online through
virtual tours
you may remember last week that that
someone
bought that six million dollar island
without ever going to see it you just
saw the picture saw the video it was
like take it yeah
well the island obviously there's not a
ton of islands for sale uh
but also there's not a lot of homes for
sale either right remember the supply is
still low
and now you get kind of this perfect
storm where
everyone's refinancing because of low
rates a bunch of buyers flood the market
because they want to buy homes with low
rates you get migration
uh trends people want to leave big
cities whatever at the same exact time
you have already a shortage of homes on
the market and
also you are getting a bunch of sellers
who are saying wait a second my house
was just worth
you know half a million dollars months
ago
what do you mean it's only worth 375 000
now they just can't get in their head
that they're actually willing to
sell it at a lower price so that's what
happens is prices just go through the
roof there's a low supply
should we buy a house where should we
buy a house leave a comment leave a
comment
on what city we should move to if we
moved out of new york city i'd love to
hear where where people
are and where you think we should move
we'll get like a lot
we're not we're not moving but let us
know where you think that uh
that we should move if we were to move
marshawn lynch
partners with fanatics to run his beast
mode online so i have no idea what i
just read what is this
okay so he did the topics i did them
today this is this is my show i i was
sleeping
yeah i did it i i see me over here
carrying the team my back hurts because
i'm carrying the squad
all the way all right all right so
uh do you remember the all-in challenge
yes where they
basically uh put together people to try
to raise money for
it all in challenge where all these
celebrities uh putting
their services up on the website for
people to bet on or
not bet on uh to to basically enter into
a raffle or to buy it so you can either
directly by the way so okay long story
short all in challenge was a charitable
thing that
i know you know about the guy who set
that up is a guy named michael rubin
yeah michael rubin is a part owner of
the philadelphia 76ers
michael rubin also owns the company
fanatics
fanatics is a business where essentially
what they do is it's an e-commerce store
and they go and they can't are you
yawning you can't stop yawning
guys this might be it she might be fired
this this may be the day
sleeping on the job we made it on the
journey
you know what you know what the sign at
starbucks says look the sign at
starbucks says a yawn is just a cry for
coffee
oh fact i need my coffee yeah you did i
see i went to starbucks and i got her
coffee she ain't drinking but you
hit it that's fine uh i put in the
microwave so it would stay warm because
i'm a
nice guy maybe
i should change my name on this to mr
nice guy all right so the whole thing
about fanatics is they
i'm done i'm done this is the last one
the whole thing about fanatics is
basically that uh they go and they
partner with leagues or
teams and they run their e-commerce
stores but this is the first time that
they've chosen to work with an actual
athlete and my guess marcia online shops
has beast mode which is his brand and
his whole story
they do that of course they just do a
partner they do a deal right so
what they basically said to him probably
is hey come bring your store over here
we'll run all the operations we'll run
all the infrastructure
and in exchange for doing that we get a
piece of the revenue
right my guess is that there's going to
be an explosion
of athletes that try to go do deals with
them uh and fanatics is one of those
businesses that like i don't think
people really understand how
valuable it is um i i don't know what
the actual value is here right
yes but what they do is they basically
partner with the league so a lot of
people would go to the nfl and they
would say hey look give me a license and
then i'll sell
all the uh the licensed content are you
about a yawn again
all the licensed content and then i get
a piece you get a piece whatever what
they do though is they go to the nfl and
say we'll actually run your ecommerce
store
so like we're the infrastructure that
runs the nfl or nba whatever
and so they just accrue a bunch of value
speaking of commerce
what's going on with walmart so walmart
what hold on a second do you know what
walmart plus is i love that she hasn't
read the
topics yet yes you come unprepared to
work you're going to get
fired we're going to write you up i'm
going to write not only did i come
unprepared i'm also yawning it's just
this is not a good reflection on my work
ethic
um it's okay you're rusty but don't but
don't worry i'm gonna deliver with the
jokes today
um so walmart plus lady's been married
for a week and a half and already she's
sleeping in she's yawning on the job
walmart plus isn't that amazon prime's
competitor yes
version well the the title says what
walmart plus offers and how it compares
to amazon prime right so yes it is a
competitor
walmart plus recently launched and it
will be 98
per year and include many of the same
services as amazon prime
but it will cost about twenty dollars
less wait wait wait but i want to talk
about this this is what i want to talk
about
you love sam's club so well the the
whole idea behind walmart plus
it's down here is what they offer same
day delivery on groceries and other
items
discounts on gas early access to product
deals reserve delivery spots and open
slot notifications
so basically what walmart's trying to do
is they're trying to take their
online uh business which has been
growing
um but but not nearly as much as amazon
obviously and
mesh it with these physical stores that
they have so can they
you know they're not going to deliver
you gas uh by you ordering it online
you've got to physically go somewhere to
get the gas
you're not going to uh get that much
benefit that you can't get with amazon
simply by having an online only
experience with walmart so they said
well why don't we do things like
offer discounts on gas why don't we give
you preferred parking at our stores
why don't we actually give you sorry but
two day free shipping for orders more
than 35 dollars which i think is less
than amazon yeah well i mean amazon
prime has shipping
benefits and things like that too so
it's just like here we go right
amazon pioneered this amazon was able to
take their cost centers turn them into
profit centers and now we've got
somebody like a walmart who's going to
try as hard as they possibly can
to compete my guess is that they steal
some market share
but uh the question is do they steal it
from amazon or do they just steal it
from other retailers who amazon's been
crushing as well sorry i need to talk
otherwise i'm gonna
yawn um did you know that walmart claims
that 90
of americans live within 10 miles of a
walmart
that's not surprising walmart's
everywhere yeah of course all right
let's talk about china
i snuck this topic and she didn't even
know we're about to talk about she's
gonna be real mad
she's gonna be me she hates when i talk
about this stuff but when i do the
topics and you sleep and guess what
happens
i already had topics guys only one of
mine made it on here
well too bad you snooze you lose
literally
all right so you the u.s the united
states
go ahead oh if you want to leave it for
the first time ah go ahead i'll just
take a little break since you
took a break all morning
[Applause]
this is what i was doing all morning
actually just waiting
he keeps trying to wake me up at all
hours in the night
and he's like hey hey hey and now it's
like oh she's sleeping
i wake up early and i do work and i work
all day
and then i go to sleep late because i'm
working i sound like
i'm a machine you're inefficient with
your time i'm a machine
the us orders closure of chinese
consulate in
houston the united states government has
abruptly ordered china
to cease all operations and events at
its consulate in houston
texas in what china is calling the the
chinese foreign ministry is calling this
an
unprecedented escalation in recent
actions taken by washington the u.s
claims it's protecting american
intellectual property and america's
private information
we're not sure exactly what that means
the u.s hasn't clarified
but they basically said your consulate
in houston shut it down
immediately uh but but it says that
it says that a spokes as spokesperson
for the state department
said in a separate statement that china
has engaged for years in a massive
illegal spying and influence operations
and those activities have increasingly
market markedly in scale
and scope over the past few years yeah
basically the whole idea is
china's doing something out of that
consulate that the u.s has been aware of
there finally had enough they told me
shut it down
china's acting as if like this is some
oh my god this is unprecedented action
you're uh
ratcheting up our uh this the stress
yeah you're the stress between the us
and china and we're gonna retaliate
against you
china who cares who cares
you're here because we let you be here
if you do things that we don't like rip
it doesn't it
yeah it doesn't worry you that they
didn't even say why
almost here's a hot take that's why i
plain doesn't like when i talk about
this stuff
right now every single person if you ask
them what is one of the greatest
genocides
in history they'll tell you something
that happened in an african country hold
on
something that happened in african
country or something like
uh the nazis in germany that's what
people would say right now
is one of the greatest genocides in
history what is occurring right now in
china
if you go and you look they are
literally taking an entire demographic
of their citizens
they're shaving their heads they're
putting them in these camps and they're
killing them
listen if people don't start talking
about it history will not be kind to you
what
doesn't it bother you that they didn't
explain why they shut it down
why should they have to because they're
just gonna start shutting everything
down
for no reason oh okay it's like saying
that this is literally the way i think
about it it's hypocritical no it's like
saying that the u.s has allowed nazi
germany to set up a consulate here in
the united states
who cares what the reasoning is whether
they're actually spying whether it's
just that we disagree with what they're
doing in their own home country
whatever they're here at our invitation
we don't want them here anymore
according to the state department that's
not my opinion that's what the state
department's saying so they're telling
them shut it down
they didn't kick them all out they
didn't shut down every consulate it's
this specific one
and look would i like to understand it
better sure
but i also understand whenever you get
into things like illegal spying
influence operations all that stuff
yesterday you didn't believe the
government on anything today you believe
someone else i'm not saying that i
believe them
i'm just saying that at the end of the
day if the u.s just says we don't want
you here anymore
just because okay so what if he he the
government comes to your business says
we don't want you to operate anymore
shut it down shut it down no this is
different though how's the difference
because this is a foreign country
that is here on our invitation i'm an
american citizen
right i'm protected by the constitution
i have certain rights
by being an american citizen these are
not american citizens this is a foreign
country
which many people would argue were
actually engaged in conflict with
an economic war right um a geopolitical
war
and so they're literally here in our
country
who cares why the government wants them
out if the government says they want
them out and that's their right
i don't know you disagree i think there
needs to be more checks and balances
and more transparency but that's just me
all right well what is let me ask you
this what is the danger with shutting it
down
like what are you worried about i just
don't like the government shutting
things down with
no transparency with no oh i don't want
to tell you what the government does all
around the world then because they do
that every day
everywhere else well i don't like it it
doesn't change my mind
that's fair uh okay did you just give me
with like the table that says change my
mind and the guy said they're drinking
the coffee like the mean
yeah okay just what's going on but i
don't want you to change my mind because
i won't change my mind so it doesn't
really matter if you change my mind
okay changing your mind is a sign of
intellect yeah obviously you can't do
it what
oh i thought you mean like being able to
change somebody's mind as a sign of
intellect
guys she's real rusty there's some
cobwebs
going on up there today was there a
shadow on my face you didn't even do the
blinds
come on let's go let's go what's going
on with the happy pointed
today okay see that guys i found i
literally googled happy headlines
because i figured we'd end on a good
note today like i like this one and
there's a website called
myhappyheadlines.com
a man graduated with a nursing degree
from the same university where he
started as a janitor
yes this is such a paulina story my guy
started as a janitor he's
literally the epitome of started at the
bottom and now we're here
graduated he's 29. he's got a nursing
degree he was a teenager when he was
working as a gender it wasn't like too
recent
but oh okay yeah but on monday 29 he
graduated with a nursing degree
he could barely speak english when he
started working at nyu and now
he literally graduated he started as a
janitor who could barely speak english
and now at 29 years old he's walking out
with a nursing degree
bang bang that's what the world's about
all right hold on
what dumb joke do you have this joke
better be good or
this is it it's we're done now i'm
literally putting a line in the sand if
this joke's not good
the joke section actually i actually
have two jokes and these two jokes come
from
um from our people from lunch money
uh viewers i keep calling them readers
lunch money viewers
who commented yesterday but hold on a
second
i have a joke for you that i came up
with okay
your jokes operate
outside of the the laws of supply and
demand because they're all supply and no
demand
there's literally no demand for your
jokes that's why i'm the only one
telling jokes
okay we've got a lot of supply that
nobody demands
your hair looks funny all right ready so
why um yeah that was joe
telling you that i was funny no it's
when i said your hair looked like then
it showed up
we'll go back to the tape go ahead okay
what do you call a cow with no legs
a fat ass cow
no why is it going to be fat if has no
legs
because it broke his legs no trying to
walk around all that fat
no it's um ground beef
that's a very good one who said who who
sent that joke i right now i can't find
who sent that joke in hold on let me
tell my other one and then i'll find the
beef one
okay all right this is by david layton
what do you call a dog who does magic
a one-trick pony cadabrador
david come on man if you're gonna take
the time to go on the youtube comments
and leave that
leave that joke we got us we gotta
improve the joke quality ground beef
was by david jeffries if your name's
david and you're leaving jokes in the
comments we gotta we gotta talk
your name is david and you're leaving
jokes in the comments we gotta talk
because you gotta up the game you're
giving davids around the world a bad
name i thought they were
stupendous tremendous
okay trump that's it for lunch monday
today guys hopefully tomorrow polino
won't be sleeping in yawning
not understanding the topics just
generally putting up a b
plus performance oh come on b plus is
better than a c minus
i showed up i gave it my all did you did
you give it your all
yes i did okay that's it for lunch
monday today well while she's trying to
get rich the rest is trying to get our
lunch money right
hopefully planner doesn't nap the rest
of today and we'll see you tomorrow be
more exciting then
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends